Code reviews are the new big problem in
software development. At PostHog, we're
merging six times as many pull requests
a week now than we were just a few
months ago. That's six times as many new
features, performance improvements, UX
tweaks, bug fixes, and of course, six
times as many new PRs that need
reviewing. Now, some will argue that
reading and understanding every line of
code that an LLM commits is the only way
of avoiding shipping AI slop, but that's
just wrong. If you need to be involved
in every code review, you will always be
the bottleneck. You're just trading one
problem, which is writing the code, for
another, which is reviewing it. In this
video, I'm going to share with you the
real skills, loops, and mental models
that PostHog's engineers use to solve
this problem, so you can keep shipping
fast and do so reliably. So, without
further ado, let's get into it. Okay, so
the first thing we need to ship AI code
reliably is an independent code review
loop. This is necessary because agents
are really bad at checking their own
work. They're overconfident and unaware
of their own blind spots. The goal here
is to offload the simpler reviews to
agents and flag whenever something
genuinely needs our attention. Now, Paul
Danbra, an engineer at PostHog here on
the exact team, solves this by using a
multi-agent loop review system that has
two stages. First, his QA swarm skill
spawns four review agents, each with
their own special instructions and
adopting different models based on their
suitability for the task. QA swarm
spawns technical sub-agents that hunt
for security, database, and performance
problems using Fable. Security audit
probes for vulnerabilities like SQL or
prompt injections, also using Fable.
Paul reviewer uses Paul's voice and
focuses on observability, naming, and
rollouts. This one uses a cheaper model.
Finally, XP reviewer applies an extreme
programming lens, checking for things
like readability and best practices.
Next, a review triage skill source those
reviews to classify threads into three
different categories. Actionable threads
that get fixed and pushed automatically
without human input, knits for smaller
things like style comments, which are
resolved and replied to silently, and
most importantly, ambiguous threads that
get escalated to Paul for him to pair
with an agent and resolve. This system
runs on a loop up to three times until
no new actionable threads appear. Now,
running a multi-agent system like this,
well, it can get expensive. Around 60%
of Pulse token spend is burned on
automating the toil of handling CI and
review, but according to Paul, it saves
him so much time and energy that he
doesn't regret a single dollar. We could
do a full video on Paul's review skills,
so let us know in the comments if you'd
like to see that. There's also links to
Pulse's QA Swarm and Review Triage skill
in the description, and there's a prompt
you can copy and adapt to create your
own review skill. If you can't afford to
run a multi-agent system like this, try
a single-agent design like No Mistake,
an MIT licensed tool that acts like an
AI-powered quality gate between you and
your Git remote. The next big problem
you need to solve is context switching.
It's a silent productivity killer, and
coding with AI forces this on us all the
time. One solution is to pair a review
loop like Paul's with a PR babysitting
skill like the one created by Phil Hack
on our feature flags team. His babysit
PR skill eliminates context switching by
regularly checking all of his open PRs
and classifying them as either quiet, CI
failing, or pending, or new comments. If
CI is failing, you can call the
dedicated CI monitor skill to resolve
it. You can use the loop command to turn
this into a cron job that runs at
regular intervals, ensuring that all
your open PRs are in a mergeable state
without you having to check them by
hand. Now, the next thing you need is a
system for stamping small, low-risk pull
request. We used to handle this inside
of our Slack channel, and we even had a
leaderboard that kept track of the most
helpful engineers, but we built a Stamp
Hog agent to lighten the load. How it
works is our engineers add a Stamp Hog
label to their pull request on GitHub,
and it runs a safety check before
anything is approved. First, it checks
the PR state to ensure that pull
requests are ready to be merged by
looking for requested changes and any
merge conflicts. Then, it analyzes the
blast radius, which is a deterministic
deny list. So, it checks if the files it
touches match any list of sensitive
areas such as auth, secrets, billing,
and so on. It also checks the diff size
to ensure that the pull request is under
500 lines of code and is under 20 files
changed. Only if it clears all three
does an LLM actually read the diff
looking for showstoppers. If an agent
approves, it leaves a bare GitHub
approval with no line comments.
Otherwise, it refuses or escalates with
a one-to-two sentence reason, risk level
rating, and next steps, which typically
mean tagging a subject matter expert.
Stamp Hog resolves more than 1,500 pull
requests every month. That's 1,500 fewer
Slack interruptions for our engineers.
Many of the inner workings of Stamp Hog
are specific to Post Hog, but you can
use a prompt to copy the adapt it to
your needs.
Our final tip is arguably the most
important. Agents are good at explaining
why their code works even when it
doesn't. That's why you should verify by
observation, not by
Why accept an argument that the code
works when you can just watch it. The
gold standard is something you can
observe directly like sending a real API
request or reading a response directly.
If the behavior is right in front of
you, you don't have to trust an agent's
rationale at all. But, this also does
have a scaling problem since a
3,000-line pull request would be
challenging to trust and observe.
Daniel's approach is to make agents
decompose the work. For large changes
like building a metrics pipeline
end-to-end, he instructs the agents to
produce a stack of small, single-purpose
pull request and then uses Graphite for
its stacking functionality. This makes
each diff independently runnable and
observable. At each step of the stack,
you can run a real check and confirm the
output matches what you expect. Then, as
you merge from bottom-up, each layer
only builds on the behavior that has
already been verified. This way, early
mistakes can't compound and when
something does break, you're debugging
one small diff instead of a whole
change. And systems like Stampede can
already auto-approve the small and
focused PRs. This is critical because
observation scales better than review.
So, when you can't trust your agent's
reasoning, don't default to reading more
code. Decompose the changes until you
can watch each piece run. You can set
this up by using Graphite or GitHub's
stack PR support system to stack the
smaller PRs your agents produce. The
instructions are actually pretty simple.
First, split the work into a stack of
small pull request, each under 400
change lines, and focus on a single
change building only on the pull request
below it. And second, every pull request
has to ship with its own test and end
with a way to observe it working
directly, a command to run and an output
you should expect. This approach is
especially valuable for front-end work
since deterministic tests don't always
capture the visuals or behavioral
functionality that you're looking for.
So, to close this out, the fix isn't to
review harder, it's to build systems
around your process so you can keep
shipping faster and do so reliably. If
you want to dive deeper into this topic,
this video was actually inspired by an
article and that's going to be linked up
in the video description. I highly
recommend you check it out. So that's it
for this one. If you found this useful,
make sure to subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you all in the next video.